thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air by clicking the
link in the description you'll also get
nebula for free the streaming platform
made by and for creators like me a
platform guard rushes to give him a
helpful push from behind that push
ensures that he makes it onto the train
but it also knocks the box out of his
arms so what's in the box what's in the
box Harry when are you responsible for
an accident imagine you're driving along
and you stop at a red light a car then
rear-ends you and sends you flying into
the car in front of you who's
responsible if you hadn't been there
there wouldn't have been an accident but
does that put you on the hook legally
speaking if you knock down one Domino
are you responsible for all of the other
dominoes falling when a butterfly flaps
its wings the effects echo outward like
ripples on a pond and no one knows where
the effects will stop and what point
though do we say that the butterfly
caused the harm at what point do we say
that the downstream ripples are too
attenuated to pin it on the butterfly
when someone's sloppy mistake puts your
life and limb at risk who must pay what
duty do we owe each other that's the
question that we must answer in the case
of poor mrs. pulsecraft she never saw it
coming
[Music]
submitted for your adjudication our
story begins innocently enough with a
family trip to the beach
the year is 1924 the place Brooklyn New
York on a hot and muggy August morning
Helen Palsgraf prepares to take her two
daughters on a long-awaited trip to
Rockaway Beach the girls have been on
their very best behavior for weeks
helping around the house working
tirelessly at their jobs in the nearby
clothing factory they diligently counted
down the days to today they earned this
break from the tiresome monotony of the
daily grind mrs. Paul's graft to worked
hard to have this rare day off she works
two full-time jobs doing back-breaking
work both as a housekeeper and as a
janitor she rarely sleeps instead
painstakingly saving every penny earned
to scrape just enough together to be
able to afford the train fare and take
the girls out for one summer day
it was meant to be a respite a breath of
fresh air in every sense but fate had
other plans
having meticulously packed their bags
the Palsgraf family slowly makes the
trek over to the Atlantic Avenue train
station at the ticket booth mrs. Paul's
breath pauses briefly considering the
expense of the tickets she looks down at
her children's filthy but beaming faces
their smiles are well worth it she
dutifully hands over her hard-earned
wages and purchases three tickets on the
Long Island Rail Road destination
Rockaway Beach the women make their way
down to the train platform as they
patiently stand in the sweltering heat
waiting for their train to arrive they
daydream about the sand the surf fresh
air that await them little did they know
they would never reach their destination
meanwhile several blocks away
a man is abruptly awoken by the
thump-thump-thump of his landlord's fist
pounding on his door will call this man
Hot Mess Harry Harry starts this morning
like most warnings running two steps
behind he is over selecting he is three
months late on the rent and knows that
his landlord is inching ever closer to
fulfilling his frequent promise to break
his legs if he doesn't come up with the
money soon in just in case he has
momentarily forgotten the landlord
reiterates the point
barking through the door to come out and
that he knows he's in there
Harry scoops up his rumpled clothes from
off the floor and throws them on as
quickly and quietly as possible he hops
around the room shoving his feet into
his shoes while trying to simultaneously
button his shirt he turns raises the
bedroom window and prepares to sneak out
down the fire escape but he pauses and
doubles back to grab a large box before
hang out through the back box in hand
Harry now tears down the street and into
the train station leaving a path of
chaos and destruction in his wake
come hell or high water he has to make
it to the Train but Harry pauses for a
moment at the bottom of the stairs
leading up to the train platform panting
he swears to himself wishing that he
weren't being slowed down by the weight
of this inconvenient parcel it's heavy
but he's got to get rid of that damn box
just then he catches a glimpse of the
Train
it's already here he picks up the pace
throwing caution and innocent bystanders
into the wind as he Sprint's up the
stairs the train crew is making their
final preparations to leave the station
this is gonna be a close one he reaches
for the Train just as the doors begin
closing the crew pity him but time in
the Long Island Rail Road wait for no
man Harry makes a desperate leap onto
the now moving train a platform guard
rushes to give him a helpful push from
behind that Bush ensures that he makes
it onto the train but it also knocks the
box out of his arms so what's in the box
what's in the box Harry fireworks legal
eagles the box is chock-full of
fireworks and what happens next depends
on who you ask
it's a narrow way in the first scenario
the train employees push knocks the box
out of Harry's arms and into the air for
a moment it seems to float suspended in
midair but then it begins its inevitable
descent downward taking an unlucky
bounce off the very edge of the platform
it ricochets off and bounces again this
time off the side of the train itself
and then continues bobbling its way down
onto the train track cavity itself where
it eventually settles into its final
resting place lodged between the two
track beams inches from the train wheels
which have begun to move out of the
station at this point it's worth noting
a piece of metal on the undercarriage of
the trains caboose which loosened over
the years of wear and tear juts out ever
so slightly to one side perfectly
aligned on a collision course with the
box
this metal occasionally scrapes against
the tracks creating a burst of
screeching sparks when it does and just
as the caboose passes near the box the
metal meets the track again the ensuing
spark set off just one firework at first
then another until like popcorn all of
the fireworks go off in a rapid
succession
the explosion causes a stampede as
panicked passengers push and shove their
way towards the exits luggage is left
behind knocked over first open and
trampled on undershirts nightgowns
toiletries are strewn about the floor
people shout trying to find their loved
ones in the thick smoky fog in the
middle of it all mrs. Paul's Graff
blindly searches for her way out she
cannot see the man fumbling pastor who
himself unable to see knocks into an
enormous floor scale at just the right
angle to cause the scale to topple over
and it comes down right on top of poor
mrs. Paul's graph that's right folks
an industrial heavy brass guess your
weight old tiny scale though not so
old-timey for mrs. Paul's graph the
scale is coin-operated and those coins
now begin to slowly trickle out clunking
her right on top of her head as it
slowly crushes her with all of its
mighty weight or the second scenario
maybe it happened like this the train
employees push knocks the box out of
Harry's arms the box a veritable powder
keg immediately explodes upon impact on
the ground floor so the explosion is so
powerful that it knocks the scale next
to mrs. Paul's graph over and it falls
right on top of her with its mighty
weight either way these particular facts
are unimportant the point is that mrs.
Paul's graph is badly hurt her
daughter's rushed to her aid still
pinned under the crushing weight of the
scale she meekly tells them that she's
very sorry but she doesn't think she'll
be able to join them at the beach today
she's in shock and denial unable to yet
comprehend that her life has been
irrevocably changed she suffers bruises
all over her body and experiences
chronic headaches
doctors will later diagnose her with
traumatic hysteria
she develops a stammer and becomes
depressed she is no longer able to work
and must give up both of her jobs she
requires expensive medicines and brown
the clock hair her bones eventually heal
but mrs. Palsgraf is never quite the
same
when she is lucid enough to recount the
events of that fateful August day and
helplessly watch the medical bills pile
up she is above all else angry but this
is America and someone has to pay for
what happened to her but what about Hot
Mess Harry while clearly he's at fault
here and should be liable for the
damages that's not what this story is
about Harry never paid mrs. Palsgraf a
dime for two reasons
one he didn't have any money and two he
was never seen or heard from again
and even if mrs. Palsgraf were able to
track him down and he were served with a
lawsuit he would have been useless to
her he's what we call judgment proof
meaning that he wouldn't have had the
funds to cover a judgment against him in
any case this is often a sad reality
about litigation and with nowhere else
to turn
mrs. Paul's Graf sues the Long Island
Railroad company she claims that the
railroad was negligent when its employee
pushed Harry on to the train and
although Harry is primarily at fault she
was also harmed by the negligence of the
railroad company at trial a jury Awards
her six thousand dollars in damages
around $900,000 by today's standards but
the railroad appeals mrs. Paul's Graf
wins again
and finally the case makes its way all
the way up to New York's highest court
the Court of Appeals the issue on the
table was the Long Island Railroad
Company negligent towards mrs. Palsgraf
could they have foreseen that someone
would bring fireworks on the train in
other words what exactly is negligence
we now turn to Albany where courtroom
proceedings are just getting underway
this Court has had the opportunity to
review the record our counselors ready
for oral argument yes your honor
William McNamara representing the
appellant the Long Island Railroad
company Matthew would sir representing
the appellate mrs. Helen Paul's graph ok
then gentlemen let's get started
thank you and may it please the court
your honors my client the Long Island
Railroad has been accused of negligence
toward Helen Palsgraf when one of its
employees helped a passenger onto his
train by giving him a supportive nudge
aboard there was no negligence here how
could we possibly expect that employee
to know that the Box in the passengers
arms was packed with fireworks
there was no signage or any other sort
of indication that the box contained
dangerous contents there was simply no
way for a reasonable person to know that
if this particular box were dropped it
would explode my client was not
negligent on the contrary the employee
was doing the right thing don't we want
to live in a society in which people
feel able to help each other rather than
second-guess every move they make and
fear of future liability the passenger
is the only one to blame here your
honors and the railroad was clearly
negligent here the employee pushed the
man out of the Train far too hard his
carelessness forced the passenger to
drop the box which directly caused the
explosion that has devastated for mrs.
Palsgraf if not for the railroads
actions mrs. Paul's graph would not have
been injured it's a logical certainty
mr. McNamara let's assume that the
railroad employee was in fact negligent
here with regard to the passenger would
mrs. Palsgraf be entitled to damages
your honors even if we accept that there
could have been negligent
gents in how the employee helped the
passenger board the train that remains a
matter exclusively between the passenger
and my client mrs. Palsgraf
just has nothing to do with it your
honors my client has everything to do
with it she did everything right that
fateful August day she was a paying
customer on the Long Island Rail Road
who obeyed all the rules minded her
business and waited exactly where the
railroad told her and what exactly would
you suggest that the railroad owes to
paying customers councilor and the
railroad owes mrs. Palsgraf and all of
its customers a duty of care and it
breached that duty when its employees
negligence created an unsafe environment
causing my clients harrowing injury if
an injury can be traced back to a
wrongful act and there are no
intervening events that is sufficient to
establish liability but if we hold the
railroad negligent to mrs Palsgraf
where do we draw the line we simply
cannot hold my client responsible for
the consequences of all actions no
matter how extraordinary or bizarre that
impact customers of the railroad the
duty of care must be limited to those
who are reasonably foreseeable under the
circumstances counselor don't you think
that mrs. Powell's Graf's injuries were
reasonably foreseeable though
regrettable her injuries were not
foreseeable who could know that the box
would explode upon falling and that that
explosion would knock over a scale all
the way across the platform and that
scale would somehow topple on top of her
the chain of events here is too tenuous
but my client was foreseeable Your Honor
she was in the zone of foreseeable
danger mrs. Paul's graphs close physical
proximity to the careless Act matters
here she was waiting on the designated
platform for her imminent train about 10
feet from the site of the explosion she
was clearly at risk of direct physical
impact mr. McNamara what do you say to
that
even if we accept the zone of danger
test mrs. Palsgraf
was still too far away from the
explosion to have a successful
negligence claim under that standard it
is definitely not reasonably foreseeable
that a scale all the way on the other
end of the station could fall on top of
her as a result of one employees
careless push there are just too many
variables in between the two occur
thank you gentlemen this matter is
adjourned chief judge and future Supreme
Court justice Cardozo wrote the decision
of the New York Court of Appeals in what
is considered by many to be the single
most influential torts case in all of
American jurisprudence do you have what
it takes to think like a future Supreme
Court justice pause this video put on
your favorite black robe and grab your
gavel and let me know in the comments
how you think this case was decided all
wait
Cardoso sided with the railroad company
and found that they did not have a duty
of care to mrs. Palsgraf her injuries
were not reasonably foreseeable because
the explosive box didn't appear to be
dangerous and a reasonable person would
not have foreseen that a scale would
topple on top of mrs. Palsgraf as a
result of the box falling and exploding
not only was her judgment reversed but
mrs. Paul's graph actually ended up
owing the Long Island Railroad company
five hundred and sixty dollars to cover
their attorneys fees the equivalent of a
year's worth of her wages this case is
probably the most famous American tort
case in all of jurisprudence its legacy
however has eroded over time the
dissents in this case found that because
there was little to no gap in time or
space between the train employees
negligence and mrs. paul scraps injuries
the injuries were a natural consequence
of the series of events that followed
and while some states still follow
Cardozo's approach and find no liability
for an unforeseeable plaintiff most
states now agree with the dissent and
focus on the proximity and time and
space to the negligence and the
plaintiffs injuries this true crime
series is a huge experiment for this
channel I hope you like it because it
takes about ten times longer than all of
my other normal videos this is a huge
experiment because sometimes publishing
on YouTube is risky this video in fact
probably got demonetized
which is why my creator friends and I
teamed up to build our own platform
where creators don't need to worry about
demonization or the dreaded out
it's called nebula and we're thrilled to
be partnering with curiosity stream
nebula is a place where creators can do
what they do best create it's a place
where we can both house our content and
free and also experiment with original
series that probably wouldn't work on
YouTube in fact if you liked this
episode of the K sub you can find an
extended version that I actually can't
show on YouTube it's League legal but
now with 10% more murder and when I said
nebula is built by creators fourth
graders I really mean it nebula features
lots of YouTube's top education creators
like Lindsay Ellis Joe Scott Kent obento
Kirk azad and tons of others we get to
collaborate in ways that wouldn't really
work on YouTube for example the nebula
exclusive series called working titles
where every episode a different creator
breaks down their favorite TV intro
sequence recently Thomas Frank did
gravity falls now you see it covered the
Simpsons and I'll be doing Law & Order
very very soon
seriously we worked really hard on this
and we're all really proud of the
results the project is self-funded not
backed by investors and we've managed to
make this ad free and with no dreaded
algorithm so what does this have to do
with curiosity stream well they love
educational content and educational
creators so they're the perfect partner
for nebula and we just recently worked
out a deal where if you sign up for
curiosity stream with a link in the
description not only will you get a free
one-month trial for curiosity's dream
but you'll also get a subscription for
nebula for free and to be clear that
doesn't expire that nebula subscription
is not a trial it's free for as long as
you have a curiosity stream subscription
which means that for less than 20 bucks
a year not only to get unlimited access
to curiosity streams massive library of
gorgeous high budget documentaries but
you'll also enjoy the private playground
of youtubers best educational creators
at no additional charge and you'll be
supporting creators like me directly so
just go to curiosity stream comm slash
legal eagle so if you click on the link
in the description not only will you get
access to curiosity stream including my
favorite documentary Peter sagal 'he's
history which explains how some of the
pivotal events in US history are tied to
money like Watergate and the Civil War
but you'll also get access to nebula for
as long as you have a curiosity stream
membership
so just click on the link below and get
curiosity stream and nebula together
you'll be supporting creators and
education so what do you think do you
agree with my analysis leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist over here that has all of
my other true-crime videos including the
case of the shotgun booby trap and the
case of the genius murderers Leopold and
Loeb so click on this playlist and I'll
see you in court